welcome to this video playing bop hog
from the Netherlands is there a bob
hawke okay it's got a dog as picture
whatever I don't know if there's a
ballpark let's see nibsy union I guess I
should I should play something else was
in a wall not always the same issue ok
so the classical variation with them wow
that's actually I shoulda played III
yeah this is also valid line but not
online that I know very much know very
much about 95 bishop here ignitee forms
normally plate hmm okay now I get to get
castling in at least they don't get a
dull porn on c3 button all night be five
that's probably Bishop before him
not quite sure what the right the right
way to develop is here III is a very
maybe 52 not sure not sure really at
least here 94 I can I can take I can
still reply Bishop before
yeah well it's probably a good idea
anyway to recapture with the bishop if
black takes on c3 and he probably will
take on c3 at some point maybe 94 94
looks quite um quite a decent 94 95
Bishop b4 queen bee three and just take
on the two this should be quite quite
equal interesting 95 there is night txt
five
that's not really really great 83 takes
takes me here just maybe an improve your
move maybe queen bee one at some point
it's not easy to play this not very
familiar with the whole the whole
structure or auto a form maybe to a form
attacking the a7 pawn yeah rook takes a
look takes I don't know but okay night x
you can take G to play d5 rook takes the
c1 rook is unprotected it's still
probably them more interesting move d
595 was my idea trying to use the c6
square
and our black is fine anyway that sets a
strong really is be five even
very interesting yeah probably now
probably I should allow the capture here
b5 queen bee three is still okay his
Queen as unprotected as well it takes on
c4 I can take with the rook or the night
and very important
at least I hope there is no big big
technical drawback like that I'm missing
it should it should be okay i think i
even have 96 maybe even as an idea seems
that white know quite unexpectedly acer
is even more comfortable
here maybe just a six protecting be five
or Quincy six maybe hmm i don't need to
go to the sixth on a roof like wheat c6
i can also play 95
yeah that's that's ambitious 96 third
drawback to the smooth 96 Queen d7 night
b5 night f4 check there is a drawback
okay I just exchanged this and be
content with them being a bit quicker on
the D file check yeah it's not great but
stone okay there any way to use the
somewhat better activity Queen g5 move
like Quincy five is not doing much he's
got the week back rank but it's not
really helping protecting me too
it's it's equal anyway thrill en really
not much happening time warning check
grah offered game wrong young does ugly
nothing going on not sure if I had
something in this first I thought I'd
worse but then it looked like maybe
white should even have a little
something now here Queens is sadness
good let's let's look at the game I'd
like to like to see their eyes got
Quincy 7 that's a strong move attacking
the night yeah after that i'm basically
busted where do i go with this and he is
now threatening here whoo that was close
and after that I'm quite comfortable
computer gives ephors a good move maybe
you phone yeah yeah that's that's
interesting maybe this one counter
counter ticking I cannot do this and
it's maybe slightly better hawaika some
I'm able to dislocate the snide you know
channel here sits just equal nothing
nothing more yeah well we exchange stuff
enter then agree to it wrong yeah my
much slight problem in the opening is I
was playing Knight f3 a bit too quickly
I have some knowledge about this this
lines these lines now we had 96 and this
is not a bad line for white but I simply
have no idea how it is played here I
really don't know maybe I need to play
we should f4 instead of this rook t1
Bishop t2 I mean black has absolutely no
problem here it's got all pieces
developed and good active square since
could play on the C file so black is
certainly a completely equal here now I
would personally even prefer black in
this position the play on the C file
looks more young more dangerous in a way
because of the Queen position then why
it's play on the default and it's equal
but I would have more just in terms of
having ideas I would rather be black
here yeah I shouldn't be worse what I
what I did here was probably bad route
d2 was a bad idea just 90 to assist is
completely equal but I wanted to try
this 95 idea which is not working at all
because of quit c7 first and foremost
I have no move him simply I mean
something like that p is cutting the
same wow it's too blue really dreadful
well okay thanks for watching